the gyro can experience who's gonna win
Bernie Sanders a trouble you know Wow
everybody thought that Donald Trump's
[ __ ] and that Hillary Clinton was
gonna beat him and that no one was
concerned yeah all these people like he
doesn't have a chance Hillary's gonna be
the winner and Hillary's gonna be the
winner
that same [ __ ] could be going on with
Bernie Sanders and Trump and people got
to be real careful about that these
people to think that Bernie Sanders
can't win I don't think you understand
what's going on in this country people
are fed up with a system they're fed up
with this idea that they work so hard
and they they give their money up to
politicians and the politicians don't
really work for the people they don't
they don't can I tell you the most
annoying thing a politician says well
you know I speak for the American people
I'm like no you don't know no never not
a chance
there's not a single human that could
speak for all the member it could look
out for the interests of the American
people and I think Bernie Sanders
definitely does do that I think he's
looking out for the interests of the
working people and I think he wants
people to have a better life and do
better and I'm all for that and if that
means I have to pay more in telling
people think oh you're a socialist I've
heard people say that oh you're [ __ ]
socialist bro like first of all he's not
even a socialist he's a Democratic
Socialist it's a different thing he's
not necessary and we should all give up
our money to the institution and then
the institutions to decide how it gets
divided and you shouldn't be able to
make more than X amount of dollars
that's not what he's saying he's saying
is it should work for the people and
what he's saying is people should have
health care what he's saying is there's
a there's a lot of things that are
already socialist ideals that we use we
just forgot about it like the fire
department yep
the fire department League you don't
have a private fire department that puts
out your fire we pay for the fire
department it comes out of our taxes
pays those those very brave men and
women and then they come and they put
out your fire that's a socialist idea
public schools are a socialist idea
police are socialist idea fixing of the
roads there's a lot of things that your
money goes to the idea that you we can't
extend that and to have a better life
because of it and to have free health
care and free college education and to
eliminate student debt I don't know that
that's
correct I don't know that he's wrong
yeah I just think it's a thing where our
government to me and I'm no expert but
it seems like they throw so much money
away why not if you're gonna throw it
away do something good with it you know
and it seems like we had throwing it
away that exact that would be actually
doing something good with yeah he's got
crazy ideas and if they're right
it's revolutionary mm-hmm and that's
what he thinks he thinks he can enact
revolutionary change - free healthcare
revolutionary win pretty much the whole
yeah because it's gonna take out the
drug companies and there's a lot of
money a lot of money a lot of money
that's a big problem yes that's one of
our biggest problems is the amount of
influence that not just the drug
companies have but a lot of industry has
on the way politicians decide how to
spend your money yes and that's what he
says but it's that's that's one of the
things he's saying that makes people
scared and that's why the the Democrats
are scared of him too because they're
all getting paid as well yeah it's not
like this is a Republican thing only no
listen this is a [ __ ] this is an
established institution thing but it
also proves that like with Michael
Bloomberg spending all this money that
when he goes to Super Tuesday he's gonna
get 13% of their guesstimating about 13%
it's just and he's gonna pass up a lot
of people that have been campaigning it
shows you how much money you know even
can play in in our politics by being on
every five minutes yeah you know he's
not gonna win blowing on no he's not
gonna win it's gonna be a tax write-off
for him Jamie will be telling me about
people getting paid to say things for
him or they just like spending lots of
money on like the people posted online
like the memes and by making all sorts
of accounts like the date went after all
of it not on a top but like Instagram
accounts like the influence meme
accounts really and there's some money
strategy yeah give him some money like
hey what would we do to post this and
they are not posting the conversation
instead of what they're asking a post
which that was the strategy it's like
these weird strategies they have
think-tank spending millions of dollars
to get that done thinking it's going to
you know you know what I do like about
Bernie Sanders he's the exact and now
don't take this wrong the exact same
energy and vibe that Trump has under
loud says it like it is to him whatever
his thoughts are so really if they go
against each other it's almost the same
person I'm not talking policies at all
I'm just saying this characteristics you
know where Barney's not gonna back down
from Trump and Trump's not gonna back
down against Bernie and all these people
going well I don't know if Bernie is
electable it's like there are no rules
anymore can we just say him not being
electable yes we did ones three
primaries in a row that's what I'm
saying yeah it's just it's just for day
I'm just I'm just waiting to see how it
plays out I'm the one where it's like
you know let's just see I want to see
who the Democratic person is and and
then we all gotta roll with them if
you're on that side it's Bernie yeah I
think it's gonna be Bernie
unless he has a heart attack of the CIA
gets him with the [ __ ] election well
you know you know what it is it's not
about Bernie it's if he becomes
president who's the vice president
because Barney's old no no and I'm not
wishing anything yell but that vice
president pick is it very important
especially after the heart thing yeah
it's very important and a lot of people
are saying he should get Elizabeth
Warren because you because his age is
more dangerous than she is useful okay
like I don't know well don't trust her
after that whole Pocahontas [ __ ] all the
Indian stuff where she said she was
Native American and turns out she's like
1/100 of a percent or whatever the [ __ ]
it is but is that we small in today's
instance oh she was a Republican for
most of her career yeah and she turned
over and became a Democrat man maybe
maybe she would get the women on their
side I think but she's also an
established Democrat you know that that
takes money I think be more likely that
he would get someone that we haven't
heard of okay well it's very important
his lies president because I'm just
saying remember Mike Pence like you
already knew the [ __ ] Mike Pence was
before Donald Trump made him our vice
president you go on the street and ask
people who the Vice President is 99% of
them are oh no Mike Pence's yeah all
right I think the real battle is Bernie
and Trump that's a real bad no no no I
got you and I don't think the vice
president's gonna move the election but
I'm saying because well because he's all
had the heart problem yeah you know the
vice president is more important than
like an Obama vice president
that's Khalsa Gabbard makes the most
sense because she's also like him she
doesn't accept money it's the same same
sort of renegade philosophy you know
slightly different politics but you know
there's a I think he has a lot of
options he's probably looking at him
right now
especially if he keeps winning it's like
that Joe Rogan let's bring him up no
chance no well when you do note it after
he wins when you go to White House is
just just bring your boy right here cuz
I want to go to White House with you yes
the last brouhaha after he put that
video up and everybody got upset oh
he'll have you I think what's gonna
happen is we're gonna see that regular
politics the way they've been practiced
for all these years in this country with
like these two [ __ ] choices are
gonna go away and I think it's going to
be harder and harder for established
people whether it's Republican or
Democrat to to keep doing that song and
dance and having people buy it and
that's a good thing that's a good thing
[Applause]